I used to say that I my parents never
pressured me to get married but I
honestly think it was more of my parents
uh didn't maybe didn't see the value of
it um my mom constantly said that if she
had to do it all over again she would
have never got married and never had
children so that was my idea of what um
marriage was like and she just why do
you think she said that sorry I'm just G
to jump in from time to time she was um
there's so much like you've only talked
for 10 seconds there's so much like wait
hold up go yeah okay I think she
generally just I she used to talk about
a gentleman that she thought that she
should have married uh a lawyer and I
think she generally I mean she
occasionally say stuff like I didn't
think I would ever have to work I think
I would my I thought your dad would take
care of me and she was a nurse my
parents stayed together their entire
life until she passed in 2019 they're
married for 51 years um but they did not
have a very um what I would call very
loving and my dad sat in the chair and
my mom sat on the couch like um I didn't
there was in a lot of affection that was
going on so um it maybe he wasn't her
first choice or probably so yeah um she
even she even said very much so that um
he had proposed and she put the ring
away then her mother had said you need
to either marry this guy or you need to
let him go and I think she said that she
just was like H might as well no one
else is really around how old when she
got married she was 23 and she died in
2019 yeah a little bit older for that
generation yeah yeah but today standards
right but she had done a lot she went to
New York and went to uh work for a while
and then I think um so I think she kind
of had a little bit of a party kind of
thing and came back home to Back Home In
Georgia and then our mom was probably
like Mom and Dad were like okay you're
23 you can't stay here you got to go
yeah so that's what I think all right
sorry to interrupt I keep it's okay um
so there was there was never any
pressure I never bought a guy home never
um I had attempted to bring one home and
my mom bribed me with uh tried to Bri me
with jury to break up with him and my
dad never had any conversations about
marriage or anything I had a
conversation with him over Christmas and
he said I said dad I you know I that's
my biggest regret and he said yeah and I
know it was kind of a thing I I feel bad
for you that that happened then
also um friends you know you take advice
from your girlfriend so if you don't
have if you're not if you're dating and
you don't know what you're doing and
you're not and you're failing at it and
you go talk to your girlfriends they
don't know what they're doing you got
talk the guys all they're trying to do
is get in your pants um you can't talk
to your parents because they're going to
impress you to no you don't do that and
then if you say it to society it's um
you don't love yourself you don't eat a
man go get you career just get you a
friend so there is never a sense of that
pressure on me and the part of the
reason that I really reached out was um
because I was actually out on a date and
I was driving by we were in a car and I
saw this sign of a baby and I thought
this is never going to be me I totally
missed out I will never have a baby I'm
too old um and people can say you can
dot but come on let's let's be for real
I'm I'm too old and I realized that I I
really I drank the Kool-Aid and focused
on the career I have a master's degree I
have a doctorate um when relationships
didn't work out I just switched to
getting more degrees and focusing on
careers and I have my own home I have a
car um I have all the things that people
would say as an independent woman and
nobody cares absolutely no guy cares and
I've changed completely changed the way
that I've started date because I reached
out to guys that didn't ask me out on a
second date and I said why didn't you
ask me out again I thought we had a good
time and they said I didn't think you
were interested and I'm like gosh why
not and they're like I I don't know I
just didn't think you were interested
and I realized I lead with I used to
lead with oh I have this I have that and
I you know I have all these things and I
have this all these degrees and stuff
and I completely switched and now I shut
up I focus all my attention I touch them
a little bit I compliment them a lot I
don't ever say anything about my degrees
they don't know about I have a Tesla
they don't know about the Tesla until
they walk me out to the car I don't talk
about owning a home I don't talk about
my career as a a college professor any
of that and they all call back they all
want a second date so yeah it it works I
really hope you guys enjoyed that clip
if you want to watch the full length
podcast you can find that over here that
clips from if you're new to the channel
make sure you hit subscribe over here
and pin down below in the top comment
you'll find a bunch of useful links to
my website my supplement L books and a
bunch of other stuff have an amazing day
peace out